depuis près de deux ans lakovic 19 a
fait de notre quotidien un véritable
cauchemar mais lorsque nos journées se
terminent le cauchemar ne s'arrête pas
car pour bien des gens la pandémie s'est
infiltrée jusque dans leurs rêves je
rêve beaucoup plus et plus intensément
étrangement je fais des cauchemars de
fin du monde depuis le début la pendue
avec des blessures légères et vu que
j'étais
la pandémie a engendré chez beaucoup de
gens des rêves anormaux mais aussi plus
fréquents des chercheurs ont voulu
comprendre pourquoi
c'est une des études les plus étranges
que j'ai mis ma vie en main la
chercheuse spécialisée en sommeil
rebecca robillard a interrogé plus de
5000 canadiens pour comprendre comment
leur sommeil a été perturbée par la
pandémie vous les décortiquer différents
aspects du sommet comme par exemple à
quelle heure les gens se couchait keller
et solvay quels facteurs pouvant
influencer la qualité de leur semaine
elle a constaté que la moitié des
répondants ont vu leurs semelles
chamboulé
on ne trouvait en fait trois groupes
d'individus qui ont changé leurs
paramètres de salaire durant la pandémie
nos nuits sont composés d'une succession
de phases d'endormissement de sommeil
léger de sommeil profond ainsi que de
sommeil paradoxal
c'est durant cette dernière phase que
nos rêves se produise la docteur
rebillard à constater qu'avant la
pandémie les gens avaient en moyenne
quatre phases de sommeil paradoxal par
nuit
depuis le début de la pandémie douze
pour cent des répondants disent s'être
couché plus tard que d'habitude et
s'être réveillé plus tôt ils ont donc
écourté leur nuit
64 % des participants se sont couchés à
la même heure que d'habitude mais se
sont réveillés plus tard dormantes ainsi
plus longtemps ils ont donc eu plus de
phase de sommeil paradoxal et plus de
rêves
finalement 19% des dormeurs ont décalé
leur nuit de sommeil en se couchant et
se levant plus tard étonnamment eux
aussi ont rêvé plus est étant donné que
le sommeil paradoxal tant un survenir
plus tard durant la nuit de façon plus
proéminent donc on a plus de sommeil
paradoxal on rêve plus longtemps par la
fin de la nuit mais pourquoi ces rêves
sont ils plus intense que d'habitude on
sait que quand on est stress on a
tendance à avoir des rêves qui sont plus
vides qui sont plus à charge et
émotivement aussi puis on sait que et
grèves qui ont une plus forte charge
émotive qui sont plus saillants on va
aussi faire en sorte qu'on veut sans
rappeler le plus facilement dans les
derniers mois je me réveille le matin
avec le sentiment très vif du dernier ce
soit par quem joueurs en vie à
l'université harvard
la chercheuse en psychologie du louis
barret a voulu savoir en quoi
consistaient ces rêves soa one dès le
début de la pandémie comme j'avais déjà
étudié plusieurs autres crises et leurs
effets sur les rêves j'ai décidé de
créer un questionnaire pour demander aux
gens à quoi ils rêvaient
jusqu'à maintenant elle a recueilli et
analysé plus de quinze mille rêves
soumis par des gens de partout à travers
la planète et la majorité de ses rêves
sont plutôt des cauchemars
la chercheuse s'était déjà intéressée
aux rêves survenus après le 11 septembre
2001 et après des catastrophes
naturelles mais elle a constaté que la
crise de la coved 19 affecté nos rêves
différemment parce que cette fois ci la
menace était d visible et abstraite
il y avait énormément de l'attak de
bestioles des nuées d'insectes volants
qui se dirigeait vers le rêveur les vers
de terre ou des armées de coquerelles ce
n'est pas un thème que j'avais vu dans
d'autres situations
je crois que c'est parce que dans
plusieurs langues le terme des beats est
utilisé à la fois pour désigner un
insecte est un virus
il y avait des baisses sur l'étrange
comme des i centipede ou d'emilie bed
qui étaient en revanche dans la pièce où
je dormais
[Musique]
pour d'autres la menace de l'aco vide
s'est manifestée différemment
des monstres invisible rodez ou attaquer
les gens et on sentait les attaques mais
on ne pouvait pas voir ce que le monstre
faisait génial
je devais me cacher avec des étrangers
quelque chose ça en est mais aucune idée
quoi quelque chose me poursuivait genre
post apocalyptique
les premiers rêves analysés par la
docteur bert est concerné la peur
d'attraper le virus mais plus les
mesures sanitaires se resserrait plus
cela en thelle signé les dormeurs
j'ai rêvé que j'étais bien en prison en
confinement solitaire
j'entendais les gardiens derrière la
portée et je leur demandais quand on me
laisserais sortir mais personne ne
répondait
bobby quand les gens ont dû rester à la
maison ceux qui étaient confinés celle
rêvée à des exagérations de cette
situation
mais ce qui était confiné avec d'autres
j'en rêvais plutôt qu'il était envahi ou
qu'ils n'avaient plus d'intimité par
exemple que tout le voisinage avait
déménagé chez eux
puis le port du masque s'est imposée il
c'est devenu l'un des rêves les plus
fréquents
dans mon rêve je réalise que je ne porte
pas de masque dans un lieu public je me
sens soudain gêné comme si je faisais
quelque chose de mal et je perds le fil
de mon rêve
[Musique]
ce que je vois récemment c'est que le
rêveur natta son masque mais au lieu
d'avoir peur il est très gêné
c'est un peu comme la nouvelle variante
du rêve classique où l'on ait ni au
public
pour certains rêveurs l'après pandémie
inspire aussi de la crainte
je vois beaucoup de rêves banquiers sur
le retour à l'école ou au travail tout
le monde a l'air pâle et tous les
collègues ont l'air d'avoir la co vide à
quoi servent donc ces rêves et ses
cauchemars si ce n'est de nous rappeler
le quotidien difficile que nous fait
vivre la colline en fait on pense que
pendant nos rêves les plusieurs
mécanismes dans le cerveau qui vont
venir extraire l'information la plus
importante de ce qu'on a parcouru durant
d'être notre réveil puis aussi digérer
tout le côté émotif malchance donc de ce
point de vue rien à voir par exemple des
mauvais rêves ou des règles sont un peu
troublant c'est pas nécessairement
mauvais c'est peut-être un signe que
notre cerveau est en train de travailler
dans le bon sens pour nous aider à mieux
faire face à la situation
ainsi ses songes aussi terrifiant soit
ils nous permettent aussi de garder
espoir je rêve que je pars en voyage que
shore avec des amis que tout est normal
comme avant quand je me réveille je
souhaite que ces règles soient vraies